llena arremete con sanciones tras la
visita de nancy pelosi la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes de eeuu a la
isla las represalias de beijing contra
washington incluyen la suspensión del
diálogo entre comandantes militares de
alto nivel
conversaciones sobre el clima y la
cooperación y la prevención del crimen
transfronterizo
tráfico de drogas y repatriación de
inmigrantes ilegales además emitió
sanciones sobre la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes- y su familia
para el ministro de exteriores chino la
visita de pelosi fue una afrenta contra
su país
pero si la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu pelosi ha hecho
caso omiso de la fuerte oposición de
china y de nuestra repetida comunicación
en realidad es bajo los arreglos
descarados del gobierno de eeuu que
hicieron esta desafortunada visita a la
zona de taiwán de china este viaje ha
impactado seriamente en la soberanía de
china
este jueves china inició ejercicios
militares en el estrecho de formosa que
divide la isla de china continental como
una muestra de poder sobre la isla que
reclama como propia para pelos y las
respuestas chinas son un pretexto para
apoderarse de taiwán
con ese fin como pueden ver los chinos
hicieron sus ataques probablemente
usando nuestra visita como excusa
permítanme terminar diciendo esto los
chinos han tratado de aislar a table
aixola y taiwán taiwán respondió a china
y asegura que defenderá a su territorio
me gustaría subrayar que no vamos a
intensificar los conflictos ni a
provocar disputas sino que defenderemos
firmemente nuestra soberanía y seguridad
nacional y nos mantendremos en la línea
de defensa de la democracia y la
libertad la visita de pelosi revivió un
viejo conflicto sobre la isla que tiene
un gobierno democrático y se considera
independiente de china